well I think all the consoles had their
ups and I mean I don't know does anyone
care anymore can you just be like I'll
just I'll just play em all my friends
have this one I have this one I think
it's pretty stupid to try to see who won
the console war yes I mean they both had
they both had good games yeah so it's
hard to say I mean some people some
people have an issue with with some
things I think some people have like an
allegiance to console I know when I was
really when I was a kid I was like like
Nintendo's better because it has the
first joystick on a controller and then
these other guys in sixth grade we're
like super scaring me and they're like
yeah Punk Playstations gonna have analog
sticks put on their controllers like no
that's just done I'm a huge Nintendo
fanboy so I was excited to see the new
3d Mario the new Mario Kart I wasn't
disappointed they're they're actually
really really cool yeah I was pretty
excited to play Saints Row 4
I knew it was gonna be pretty ridiculous
and I saw there was gonna be a dubstep
gun in it so I mean you play the dildo
bat they did not have the dildo bat in
there I know I don't know I don't know
if that's making a return for number 4
I'm pretty sure it has to we have a
signature the founder of oculus rift
newest Smosh was so apparently yeah he
was like he's like I I remember you guys
and I'm like oh oh do you work for
oculus and he's like yeah I'm the
founder so that was pretty shocking and
then I came across a game called Octodad
which
if you saw that it's basically you
control the arms and legs separately and
it's like it's like he all obviously
octopuses they're off to [ __ ] as they
like to be called have no joints so
they're just like and you're like
walking around yeah and you have goals
so one goal was to put a ring on a
wedding girl whatever she's getting
married
no wedding girl wedding girl okay yeah I
reminded me of co-op and trans simulator
was just like clunky but on purpose or
like enviro bear won game I was not
expecting at all was this indie game
called cloudberry Kingdom and it's like
a platformer and it's a lot like Super
Meat Boy and the fact that it's like
really complicated you'll try a lot of
times until you get it because you have
to get timing perfect and it's kind of
in the style of battleblock theater and
there's other flash new ground games and
it has I've never seen it in a game
before it has a random level generation
generation apply former perfect arse it
has a random platformer level generator
so every game could be different every
time you play yeah could you make
something yeah if we had like a yeah I
really don't think we're gonna have a
booth no I think there's cost a lot of
money it probably cost more than the
game and how much money we made
yeah we're not yet a big yeah like mega
studio like yeah maybe we only sold 10
billion copies of the game is that about
right 10 billion yeah like every person
on earth bought a one and a half times
yeah we're actually going to be adding
more levels to the game and a bunch of
other stuff each level has like its own
smosh song remix into 8-bit sound yeah
a lot of people notice that like no they
all noticed okay all the new levels have
new 8-bit remix songs and yeah it's
gonna be a lot of a lot of fun and we're
thinking about making some more game
maybe some more games but yeah all you
need is an internet connection a Sydney
persona and even you can make youtube
videos you just record it edit it and
upload it we aren't there already like a
billion other gaming channels on YouTube
oh yeah that's right I guess you have
pretty much [ __ ] unless you joined the
Smosh games Alliance Smosh games
Alliance is actually doing really well
we each week we have a segment on our
channel where the Smosh games dudes they
highlight different videos and Smosh
games Alliance Network about a network a
Smosh games Alliance Alliance so they
they highlight stuff that's bad stuff
that's good and people want to get a bit
out there and the people I get on the
show get you know thousands of views
that they would never have gotten before
I think it's actually doing really well